[Musik]
mal wieder allerhand wirbel und
diskussionen heftige diskussionen bei
der afg da sind wir froh dass wir mit
dem bundessprecher sprechen können guten
tag jörg nolte
schönen guten morgen haben heute fangen
wir vorne an 2,3 prozent weniger bei der
bundestagswahl am sonntag in 13 von 16
bundesländern haben sie hat die afg
zweitstimmen verloren warum unterstützen
die wähler innen sie nicht mehr so
das sind gründe die wir analysieren
müssen und das werden wir auch tun dazu
machen wir eine nachwahlbefragung um das
auch empirisch herauszufinden jeder hat
er seine erklärungsansätze wir haben das
ja schon ansatzweise diskutiert auch auf
der pressekonferenz am montag jetzt
warten wir mal an die
nachwahlbefragungen ab und dann sehen
wir woran es gelegen hat was sind denn
ihre erklärung dafür
ja ich von mir ist bekannt dass ich
gesagt habe ich glaube dass wir mit dem
wahlprogramm vielleicht auch mit dem mit
dem spitzenkandidaten wo sehr stark die
eigene klientel bedient haben und wir
haben eine stammwählerschaft die nicht
stabil bei 10 prozent die haben wir
abrufen können es ist uns aber nicht
gelungen neue wählerschichten zu
erschließen und wenn wir in diesem land
mitgestalten wollen etwas verändern
wollen dann kann man nicht da bleiben wo
wir sind in den bereich zwischen zehn
und zwölf prozent da müssen wir darüber
hinaus und dann sollen auch neue
wählerschichten erschließen das ist
erkennbar diesmal schief gegangen liegt
dieser verlust vielleicht auch daran
dass sie nach außen ein ich sag das mal
ganz zurück ein komplett zerrüttetes
binnenverhältnis in der afg offenbaren
das glaube ich nicht dass das etwas
maßgebliches wäre wenn es denn so wäre
ich würde es aber auch gar nicht ganz
komplett zerrüttet bezeichnet also dass
wir das von medien zugeschrieben dass
meinungsverschiedenheiten gibt das
persönliche sympathien antipathien gibt
es etwas was sie in jeder partei haben
das kennen sie den cdu und spd ganz
genauso ok sie haben die pressekonferenz
vom montag schon angesprochen dann
gucken wir da doch gerne noch mal drauf
da sitzen sie und ihr wahlkampf
spitzenduo die fraktions chefin alice
weidl und ihr ko parteichef tino keller
auf dem podium und so sah das dann aus
ich muss dann auch ganz klar sagen dass
ich das ergebnis bin ich und uns auch
nicht schlecht reden lassen lasse von
niemandem wir haben uns etabliert als
afd man wollte uns jahr
2017 zu einer eintagsfliege
einmalig in der legislatur machen und
uns
2021 wieder aus dem bundestag in
auswählen das ist ja seit gestern
bekannt nicht gelungen wir haben ein
stabiles ergebnis
eingefahren wir haben bei dieser wahl
das bild ist nicht zu beschönigen knapp
20 prozent unserer wähler verloren
absolut sind das fast 900.000 wir haben
in landtagswahlen die ja auch zu
erwähnen sind verloren und zwar in allen
landtagswahlen dieses jahres und nun bei
der bundestagswahl auch stimmenverluste
ich glaube dass wenn wir als als partei
wirklich erfolgreich sein wollen da
müssen wir unserem anspruch gerecht
werden unser anspruch ist mut zur
wahrheit zu haben wir können uns nicht
in allen parteien main die ergebnisse
schönreden war ja offene des erneuten
auf der pressekonferenz auch so von der
stimmungslage offene konfrontation auf
offener bühne wie soll ihre partei noch
als ernsthafte partei wahrgenommen
werden wenn man so was erlebt
ich sehe die probleme macht dekkers
solchen die chance da sind stück weit
die diskussion ist das glas halb leer
oder halb voll ich habe auch die
verluste hingewiesen die die wir haben
und damit habe ich habe ich völlig recht
und ich sage wir dürfen uns das nicht
schönreden dazu gehört eine
schonungslose analyse wenn man nicht
wahlsieger ist da muss man daran darüber
nachdenken warum die situation lasse
sich das werden wir tun nicht verraten
alles weiter sagte er sie lasse sich das
ergebnis nicht schlecht reden dass er
das maximale gegenteil von dem was sie
sagen
ja wir haben wir haben da eine
meinungsverschiedenheit in der bewertung
des ergebnisses wenn sie sagt wir haben
uns stabilisiert dann sage ich ja das
haben wir aber auf einem zu geringen
niveau wir dürfen nicht damit zufrieden
sein gerade noch zweistellig geworden zu
sein das ist die probleme hat er gern
der ganzen geschichte das kann man so
und so sehen ich finde übrigens gerade
unterwegs zu einer
bundesvorstandssitzung
nach berlin wo wir das heute intensiv im
bundesvorstand diskutieren werden auch
die unterschiedlichen positionen das
muss sein und ich halte das für etwas
völlig legitim ist dass man auch
unterschiedliche positionen hat mir noch
mal weiter herr wollten die letzten
beiden tage ging es ja weiter stunden
lang wurde da erbittert gestritten in
der neuen bundestagsfraktion die wahl
der neuen spitze der fraktion musste
sogar verschoben werden am ende sind
alle zweifel und thilo grob aller dann
gestern abend mit gerade mal zwei
drittel mehrheit gewählt worden dazu gab
es ja anträge gegen dieses prinzip der
doppelspitze und der gemeinsamen wahl
der beiden fraktionsvorsitzenden die nur
ganz knapp gescheitert sind also auch in
ihrer bundestagsfraktion herrscht der
offenbar massive uneinigkeit wie soll
wie wollen sie da die nächsten vier
jahre
konstruktive oppositionsarbeit machen
ich weiß sie sind selbst nicht im
bundestag aber trotzdem die frage als
sie als chef der partei
sie sagen es ganz richtig will
parteichef nicht habe mir schon in der
letzten legislatur zur angewohnheit
gemacht mit den belangen der fraktion
nicht einzumischen das werde ich auch
für dahin nicht tun ich habe das wohl
mitbekommen ich weiß dass das sehr
knappe ergebnisse gab auch in der in der
frage einzelwahl oder oder eben
huckepack war das war genau pari pari
das sehe ich auch aber ich werde mir da
eine zurückhaltung auferlegen weil ich
nicht fraktion will und weil ich es
schon ziemlich hielten das man so
altmodisch auszudrücken wenn ich mich
als parteichef versuchte den belangen
der fraktion einzumischen aber immer als
müssten sie beschuldigen ihren
parteichef das ist ja ihre partei es
kursiert offenbar ein papier in dem vor
allem alice weiter hart angegangen wird
sie sei leistungsschwach heißt es darin
warum leisten sie als parteichef sich so
eine spitzenpolitikerin in einem der
wichtigsten ämter ihre partei
nun dass das papier stammt nicht von mir
und hier geht es um an israels leistung
in der vergangenen legislatur das müssen
diejenigen beurteilen die der fraktion
angehört haben ich kann ganz offen sagen
weil es wie gesagt fraktion zu belangen
sind
ja natürlich aber ich kann ja nicht in
jede fraktion hinein wirken dann kann
ich anfangen in den landtagsfraktionen
auch alle unzufriedenheit darauf zu
arbeiten ich glaube das wäre eine
falsche herangehensweise an das heißt
auch der bundestag hat eine ausgemachte
gremium für sie um deutschlandweit
politik machen zu können und sie sagen
jetzt ist es will ich das richtig
verstehe relativ egal was dort passiert
es ist für alles andere als egal auch
nicht wünsche der neuen fraktion dass
sie sich nach diesem etwas rumpeligen
start schnell zusammenfindet und
erfolgreich arbeitet mir geht es
natürlich sehr stark um die sacharbeit
im bundestag also die beiden letzten
vier jahren auch gut weil wenn sie sehen
was er dafür eine sache arbeit gemacht
haben dann fand ich gehe sogar
vortrefflich und ich hoffe dass sich das
fortsetzt und nicht durch irgendwelche
personalquerelen überlagert wird aber
wenn es doch ferien geben sollte dann
müssen die die selbst lösen und ich
glaube nicht dass es dadurch besser
würde dass ich mich da ein möchte aber
die sacharbeit hängt ja möglicherweise
auch mit den personen zusammen gucken
wir gerne mal auf die person die da
jetzt für sie im bundestag sitzen da ist
die vorsitzende der kfd main-tauber
christina baum die sucht sich
rechtsextremes liedgut für eine fdp
veranstaltung aus ist eine enge
vertraute des rechtsextremisten und
ihres afd thüringen chefspion röcke dann
haben wir den für die af der gewählten
matthias helferich bezeichnet sich
selbst als freundliches gesicht des
nationalsozialismus es wird jetzt nicht
teil der fdp fraktion seien beantragt
aber wohl gaststatus und dann geht es
gegen ein ihrer abgeordneten gegen
hannes genau vom militärischen
abschirmdienst eine ermittlung und er
wird als extremist eingestuft wie rechts
ist ihre fraktion und muss sie das nicht
auch kümmern
das ist der übliche what about ist der
gemacht wird in interviews dieser art
werden sich einige personen
herausgegriffen die hier oder da
vielleicht die eine oder andere
verfehlung hatten und dann wird passt
pro toto genommen als sei das die
fraktion was übrigens helferich am lang
zeigt der einzige so nehme ich ein wort
sagen da hatte ich selbst mich im
bundesvorstand für einen
parteiausschluss verfahren eingesetzt
das fand keine mehrheit helfer richteten
mit einer sperre belegt und wenn ich
recht informiert bin wird er der
fraktion auch nicht als ordentliches
mitglied angehören
so hat sich das wohl am mittwochabend
ergeben halte ich in dem fall auch für
richtig haben wollten sie haben die
sacharbeit angesprochen also die
sacharbeit wird ja von den personen auch
betrieben und wenn dann mehrere personen
im bundestag für sie dem höchsten
deutschen gremium für das volk sitzt
wenn dort viele sitzen die extremisten
sind die im zweifel rechtes gedankengut
haben was bedeutet das dann aus ihrer
sicht
jetzt differenziert man dass man erstmal
fertig
fundamental negieren dass wir da
extremisten sitzen haben das haben wir
nicht die würden wir auch nicht dulden
wir sind durch und durch
rechtsstaatspartei der wto dynamisch
verlaufen rechtlich getan das kann man
hinten so haben die linkes gedankengut
halten wir noch mal fest rechtes
gedankengut das klingt so so anprangern
würden sie das bei linken gedankengut
auch tun ich nicht ich hab bin zwar kein
lenker aber linkes gedankengut ist
genauso legitim wie rechtes gedankengut
was wir vermeiden müssen sind die
extremistische positionen auf der einen
wie der anderen seite exakt das tun wir
wir hatten heute einen bundessprecher
der alternative für deutschland vielen
dank ihnen für dieses tagesgespräch
jeweils für nix
sehr gern